the jurogan experience it was
insane and i couldn't believe it and so
i'm like well now i need to do a
performance with that
and now i'm going to do a performance
with because the guy who who did his
name's young orb seer he was the guy
showing his nfts in the gallery he used
to work or he i guess he still works for
3d life
but he used to be behind the scenes now
he's like made his own installation he's
in fts
explain nfts to people that don't know
what you're talking about because i
don't know what you're talking about i
do
but i don't i know it's a non-fungible
token yes i'm not exactly sure what that
means
yeah yeah yeah yeah well it's just not
very fungible you know tokens are super
fungible got it these aren't very
functional i don't even know if i could
if i
if i was on jeopardy
what does fungible mean okay let's go i
think it's good [ __ ]
it's duplicatable yeah like duplicatable
maybe something let's google it yeah go
google it what is this
connected for without an individual
specimen being specified
able to replace or be replaced by
another identical item
mutually interchangeable it is by no
means the world's only fungible
commodity okay i know oh yeah i
understand it even less now yeah
i have heard fungible like done used in
economics but yeah
you can't replicate so yeah non-fungible
so basically it's like
i have i've made a little video of me
or yeah i've made a video of me a
30-second video of me like running
around
uh you know a park or something like
that if i want to make that non-fungible
then i meant it and by minting um you
use a minting service like foundation or
zora
there's a there's many others and uh you
get a crypto wallet
and uh you get the crypto wallet set up
you put money in it it's converted into
the crypto of your choice so let's say
eth which is very popular
you're right ethereum that's a very
positive token
yeah about that yeah eth yeah eth
actually it's uh but yeah
so so these are some of these nfts that
we created so so see that one on the the
very top left yeah that's
that's um that's the looking glass
holographic display oh wow
and um and so that device we made a
an nft me and my friend panther modern
his name is
brady keen check out his music it's
[ __ ] disgusting but uh
so he made the 3d gra motion graphics
and
the tvs and designed all that stuff with
the wires we shot a bunch of video
of me doing the thing he inserted them
on the tv screens
and then we formatted it it's on a loop
it's got music with it
and uh that is then put into this device
and so
i'm trying to push this phrase called
fidget
i mean the convergence of physical and
digital media so that's like a perfect
representation
because it's the nft is sold with the
device
so when you bid on it you know you win
it or whatever that device is sent to
you there's laser etching
on the back that says the name of the
piece who made it and so forth
but technically it's that unit with the
hologram so it's the world's first
holographic nft
which was bought by uh
lee what's his name charlie lee charlie
lee who created litecoin
another cryptocurrency he bought it for
almost nothing
and uh so he now has the physical unit
that has the hologram in it
and you could ostensibly just put it on
a shelf and call it good or you can use
the display to upload more holographic
stuff if you want to
so that was the first holographic nft
those other videos that you saw cycling
were just
standard here's a video we've made it in
nft but then
someone can't replicate that video they
hold the license to it
right but if you just replicate it and
have it on your laptop how's someone
going to stop you
i mean i guess if you're trying to make
money from it then right maybe you
couldn't
yeah or something like you wouldn't be
able to make money off of it you
wouldn't be able to make money off of it
i mean technically you could screenshot
it you could screen capture it
you know if it's a video um in this case
it's a hologram so you would have to
just you'd have to have a looking glass
device and then you'd have to get the
file
in order to see it which it is available
but it's stunning when you hear guys
like beeple
like bbs sold an nft for what 59
69 69 million dollars yeah he's got a
little more with his package though you
get a hair sample
oh yeah get his own hair is that his
pubes it could be i hope i don't know
he's got very long luscious beautiful so
like he sends the whole package when you
get his nft
okay so you get an image this is i think
this is like an ipad
with the image on it the one that sold
for a bunch i believe was all of
them together all in one video sort of
so all
yeah yeah i mean someone bought it for
69 million dollars in what bitcoin or
what
um yeah i think eth they have to they
have to buy the auction is in eth so
christie's you know it's like was
auctioned by christie's it was like
it was i think it was an eth and then
how would you go about being actually
rich with this
how does people go from this to being a
baller oh well i mean
well you know they bid whoever bids it
you know just like a regular auction
and then they bid using crypto and the
cryptos transferred before they transfer
the file to the
so the 69 million dollars in eth he
could actually put into his account
yes now he has 69 actual million dollars
yeah you just convert it and he can get
a ferrari
yeah you could you could get one ferrari
for 69 million the thing with etho with
some of these contracts like i don't
know specifically which one is i heard
him mention this
he has a uh it's built into the contract
so if the person who bought it for 69
million sells it for 100 million
10 percent of that goes back to his
wallet so
yeah that's right 10 million dollars
yeah you set the resale so like on ours
we did 15
which is the average catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience